[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
la communication emmanuel macron aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
tik tok est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont le désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus que nesc justement c'est une
nouvelle forme de communication assez
verticale utiliser des influenceurs pour
moissac hommes politiques personnelles
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
est dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
venez
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée ou
mais pas de réagir sur le télégramme
daté france vous pourrez prendre part
aux débats y interpeller nos invités ont
sommaire de ce jeudi 21 octobre pour
préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
français le premier ministre jean castex
soit annoncée dans quelques minutes de
nouvelles mesures d'urgence pour faire
face à l'augmentation des prix des
carburants baisse des taxes ou chèque
carburant l'exécutif réfléchit depuis
plusieurs jours à ces deux pistes
décryptage à suivre
essence mais aussi gaz et électricité
l'addition commence à être salée pour
les ménages dans cette émission tonte
rajustement de comprendre le mécanisme
du marché cette flambée des prix était
la conséquence d'erreurs politiques
l'économiste jacques sapir nous dira
tout dans son édito est qu
après avoir été banni de twitter
facebook ou youtube donald trump a
trouvé la solution et s'il imaginait son
propre réseau social son nom fu social
qui sera lancé au premier trimestre 2011
22 comme ça sont dit-il de résister face
à la tyrannie des géants des
technologies qu'ils ont réduit au
silence qu'on soit en direct des états
unis
[Musique]
se dirige-t-on vers une levée du secret
médical à l'école française le vote à
l'assemblée d'un amendement en première
lecture qui permet aux chefs
d'établissements des collèges et lycées
de connaître le statut vaccinal des
élèves suscite la polémique il surprend
proviseur et syndicats qui disent ne pas
en éprouver le besoin l'opposition
dénonce une violation inacceptable du
secret médical alors est ce que ça vous
choque vous pouvez réagir sur notre
compte et les g
baisse des taxes chèque carburant jean
castex exprime dont donc quelques
instants à la télévision le premier
ministre qui va dévoiler les mesures de
soutien aux français face à la flambée
des prix du carburant
on retrouve notre reporter guillemin
rossi devant une station essence en
région parisienne bonsoir les humains
fin du suspense donc dans quelques
instants le gouvernement qui pourrait
opter pour le chèque carburant
oui bonsoir stéphanie oui c'est en tout
cas la piste privilégiée 1 pour aider
les français face à cette hausse du prix
des carburants un carburant en effet
particulièrement cher ces temps si vous
l'avez noté stéphanie par exemple à la
station essence où je me trouve vous le
voyez derrière moi le prix du gasoil est
à plus de 1 euro 71 le sans plomb 95 à
plus de 1 euro 76 c'est faramineux alors
bien sûr on est en région parisienne à
paris plus précisément alors on sait que
le carburant est charmé tout de même la
tendance dans toute la france est la
même le gasoil le prix du gasoil a
atteint des records historiques et le
sans plomb 95 est lui aussi très très
onéreux alors vous l'avez dit on attend
d'une minute à l'autre une annonce de
jean castex sur une autre chaîne alors
concernant les solutions étudiées bien
il y avait notamment la baisse de la
fiscalité du carburant car vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir stéphanie que dans le
prix de votre litre de carburant il y a
une bonne part de taxes plus de la
moitié à près de 56 % de taxes dans un
litre de gasoil et plus de près de 58%
de taxes pour le sans plomb 95 ont
baissé les taxes auraient un effet
immédiat pour tous les français
significatif significatif pardon mais
pèserait également lourd sur les
finances publiques selon l'exécutif et
c'est précisément ce qu'il veut éviter
écouter
la mesure fiscale n'est pas la mesure
qui est privilégié par le ministère de
l'économie parce qu'elle coûte très cher
en concernant beaucoup de monde et
l'idée c'est d'avoir un dispositif le
plus ciblé possible si vous baissez les
taxes de 10 milliards d'euros en 2022 je
n'imagine pas qu'une autre majorité où
notre majorité en 2023 vallée remonter
sur dix ans ce n'est pas 10 milliards
que vous allez dépenser et mais c'est
100 milliards d'euros la baisse des
taxes sur les carburants serait aussi
selon bruno le maire une forme de
subvention des gains et aux énergies
fossiles ce qui en effet ray et bien à
contre-courant de tous les efforts de
décarbonation de l'économie alors la
piste choisie à priori par le
gouvernement jeudi a priori parce que
jean castex ammann n'a pas encore fait
son annonce ce serait donc le fameux
chèque carburant vous en avez parlé tout
à l'heure un peu donc sur le modèle du
chèque énergie que l'on connaît déjà un
chèque qui irait donc aux salariés et
aux chômeurs sous conditions de
ressources l'idée c'est d'aider en
priorité celles et ceux qui ne peuvent
se passer de la voiture pour rechercher
ou exercer une activité alors on ne
connaît bien sûr pas encore le montant
de cet éventuel le chèque carburant ni
même ses conditions de ressources mais
nul doute que le premier ministre
répondra à toutes ces questions à ces
âmes en soupe et stéphanie mercinier
marc aussi l'option le chèque carburant
en soirée dans le cloud bi léger est ce
vraiment suffisant pour des fins de mois
difficiles combien et pour qu'y
aurait-il d'autres solutions au crédit
pour contrer la hausse des tarifs c'est
l'heure de notre décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler ce soir jérôme à
rodrigues jd jaune et gilles casanova
spécialiste en communication bonsoir
messieurs merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france lieux mal disait on
atteint des records incomparable
d'ailleurs ce qui avait lancé jacques
lizé gilet jaune en 2018 jérôme
rodriguez qu'est ce que vous attendez du
premier ministre ce soir c'est tenter
que vous en attendez quelque chose
moi je crois que la preuve est faite que
on n'a pas perdu mais
on a perdu malheureusement jérôme
rodriguez qui n'a pas réussi à attendre
pour la petite histoire ce plateau pour
cause de de bouchons parisiens a
malheureusement gilles casanova il joue
gros ce soir le rond le premier ministre
les français attendent beaucoup
évidemment de ces annonces et une vraie
crispation autour de ce thème
alors nous sommes en période électorale
comme vous l'avez noté la baisse de la
fiscalité comme l'a fait remarquer le
ministre des finances ce serait une
baisse de la fiscalité pour un certain
temps alors que le chèque le chèque on
le donne jusqu'au deuxième tour après le
deuxième tour
le déluge peut arriver
l'idée c'est d'empêcher avant le
deuxième tour une fronde comme on a eu
celle des gilet jaune
il faut se souvenir d'une part que le
prix de l'essence a déjà été plus cher
dans ce pays qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui
en revanche ce n'est pas le cas du prix
du gazole et on sait que le diesel et
puis largement utilisé par les
catégories populaires et des véhicules
qu'elle utilise que par les plus les
mieux dotées économiquement qui
utilisent des véhicules à essence et
souvent même cylindrée plus élevé donc
l'idée c'est d'essayer de calmer le jeu
avec les catégories populaires le
problème c'est tout de même que ça va
coûter cher et que si c'est une usine à
gaz les personnes qui en seraient
bénéficiaires ne vont pas en bénéficier
parce que c'est trop complexe et elles
finiront par descendre dans la rue donc
c'est une équation délicate mais qui
s'arrête au deuxième tour car après le
deuxième tour il n'y a plus aucune
garantie d'aucune forme dead face à
cette flambée des prix de l'énergie et
qui sera redoublée d'une autre flambée
puisque l'union européenne s'engage à la
manière allemande dont la transition
énergétique
plutôt contre le nucléaire ce qui permet
à la france d'avoir un prix de
l'électricité malgré les augmentations
tellement plus bas qu'en allemagne et
bien mon s'engage dans cette logique là
les autres énergies vont augmenter et
donc il y a là un problème qui n'est que
le début du fils que l'on tire d'un
pull-over qui va ce trick détricoter
très vite ça veut dire c'est que
casanova si on vous suit bien que ce
soir au mieux jean castex colmate les
brèches et étouffe pour le moment les
mécontents temps
oui le but c'est simplement d'éviter un
trop gros mécontentement avant
l'élection puisque nous savons que nous
avons un gouvernement en campagne pour
le président qui se bat pour son
renouvellement
donc là on est dans une situation où
tout ce qui y est vision à long terme
est placé sous le bas de la pile des
dossiers sur le bureau et le premier
dossier c'est le renouvellement du
mandat du président et la tentative
qu'il va faire en ce sens et créer les
meilleures conditions pour cela tout le
reste peut être considéré comme un
annexe pour un gouvernement dont le
président se représente dans les
dernières semaines alors on l'a dit
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que à priori
c'est l'option du chèque qui va être
privilégié je me propose des contes et
pierre chasserait ans qui représentent
40 millions d'automobilistes qui exprime
est justement son mécontentement quant à
ce cher qu'en tout cas lui était pour
une baisse des taxes écoutez je regarde
l'échiquier politique m'aperçois qu'il
ya droit qu'on est favorable à la baisse
des taxes michel barnier vient
d'annoncer je m'aperçois avec anne
hidalgo a été la première à parler de la
baisse des taxes donc non il ya
unanimité si on prend du côté de la
droite à la droite de la droite du côté
d'eric zemmour de marine le pen on est
favorable à la baisse des taxes non non
en fait ya qu une seule personne en
france qui est défavorable à la baisse
des taxes et les écologistes mais les
écologistes c'est qui
ces personnes moi j'ai l'impression que
les verts ils sont surtout très gris
quand ma main et quand il quand il
s'agit de chercher des arguments le donc
ça c'est une constante l'on pense qu'il
faut maintenant passer à l'action arrêté
un petit peu et se dire que quand on est
président de la république on est élu
par les français aujourd'hui on pensait
qu'ils ont portés manuel macron à la
tête de ce pays ont souhaité souhaite
une baisse des taxes sur le carburant
dont tacle c'est un braquage l'entente %
de taxes comment peut-on accepter de
nous pour qu'un produit soit taxée à
hauteur de 60% et l'argument écologique
faut arrêter faut arrêter commençons à
faire aux politiques des français avant
de se paie quand même d'une minorité de
marginaux qui ont dormi plombe le pays
la bobologie c'est le cancer de la
france pierre chasserait très remonté
hier soir en direct sur ce bateau là on
est ravis d'accueillir c'est la magie du
direct jérôme rodriguez qui est apparue
de sa voiture dans les bouchons
parisiens à ce plateau est ravi que vous
ayez réussi à l'atteindre en tout cas
jérôme rodrigues je vous demandais quand
on a été interrompue par par la
connexion voilà on entend pierre
chasserait nous dire voilà moi j'étais
en tout cas pour la baisse des taxes
c'est pas forcément ce qu'on attend de
la part du premier ministre soit on va
voir ce qui va nous dire vous vous en
attendez quelque chose du premier
ministre ce soir et c'est oui moi je
pense que mon livre mettre du concret
d'accord aujourd'hui on est sur une
moyenne de 22% d'augmentation à une - 1
sur le sur les produits carburant tous
carburants confondus ce qui représente
sur un plein de 50 litres par semaine 15
euros de plus à la semaine ce qui
représente 780 euros à la fin de l'année
est ce qu'un français qui gagnent en
moyenne 800 euros par mois avaient prévu
de débourser 780 euros de plus sur son
budget initial je vous passe le fioul ou
on est à 400 euros de plus en deux mois
on est passé de 600 à 1000 euros les
mille mètres cubes fallait 1000 livres
pardon voyez ce que je veux dire ça
c'est du concret dans la poche est ce
qu'aujourd'hui si monsieur castex
propose un chèque est ce qui sera à la
hauteur de 780 euros
est ce que l'ensemble des travailleurs
pour aujourd'hui en france qui font
vivre la france seront bénéficiaires de
ce chaque c'est ça la vraie question
parce qu'aujourd'hui si le chèque
énergie est une mesurette sur les 7
milliards rapporté à l'état via la
hausse du prix du gaz où on va
redistribuer seulement 10% aux plus
modestes c'est à dire ceux qui déclarent
moins de onze mille euros de celle de
d'impôts par an l'ensemble des français
aujourd'hui ne sont pas concernés par
ces aides de l'état et c'est ce qu'on
demande aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
gilets jaunes l'ensemble des citoyens en
colère et des travailleurs de france à
voir aussi un coup de main parce qu'il
faudra appeler la voiture en mènent ces
jours-là au travail
gilles casanova ce que me dit gérard
rodriguez c'est que voilà il ya ce
risque de mesurettes annoncées ce soir
par le premier ministre certains visent
le chèque c'est une mesure juste parce
qu'elles touchent les moins favorisés
mais enfin voilà il ya les classes
moyennes dessous qui prennent la voiture
qui aurait bien besoin jérôme vegas dans
un café l'addition
de cette addition salée pour pour les
ménages à ce que quoi qu'il arrive ça
risque d'être forcément une mauvaise
mesure et a fortiori ceux chaque mais il
faut comprendre que la difficulté d'un
gouvernement en campagne électorale
c'est de ne pas décourager la petite
partie de l'opinion qui le suit avec
intensité depuis un certain temps il y à
entre 10 et 12% des français qui sont en
plein accord avec le gouvernement avec
emmanuel mâcon qui lui ont donné cette
majorité parlementaire qui
ne sont pas allés voter aux régionales
ou municipales mais qui forment disons
la base sociale et cette base sociale
elle est extrêmement sensible à tous les
discours qui touche les couches
supérieures de ce qu'on appelait
traditionnellement la petite bourgeoisie
urbaine c'est à dire le discours
écologiste le discours écologiste domine
culturellement ces catégories qui
apportent leurs suffrages de manière
décisive à emmanuel macron et à ses amis
donc baisser les taxes c'est aller à
l'encontre de ce qui est vraiment un le
choeur religieux de ceux de ce groupe et
donc il est très difficile de baisser
les taxes sur les carburants fossiles
sans risquer de perdre la
significativement un nombre de voix dont
vous voyez que l'affairé et c'est très
bien expliqué en tout cas j'ai de
casanova on vous remercie jérôme
rodrigues est en train de cynisme donc
on prend des décisions alors évidemment
on fait mine d'être étonné enfin là
quand même c'est une catégorie personnes
une poignée personne n'est pas dans
l'intérêt de tous les français savent ce
que c'est ce que vous pensez en tout cas
sans jouer sur les mots prix du gaz il
faudrait éviter de faire comme on a
l'habitude de faire en france et vers
une usine à gaz quoi aujourd'hui on est
capable s'il voulait il ya un an de
débloquer 240 milliards pour venir en
aide à ceux qui en avaient besoin je le
remets pas en cause et aujourd'hui quand
les français sont dans le besoin on nous
dit que c'est pas possible on nous sort
tout un tas de prétextes mais selon
fiscale
directe on apprend que le premier
ministre première mesure annoncée ce
soir il nous maintiendrons le blocage
des prix du gaz sur toute l'année 2022
voici la première annonce de la soirée
est ce que c'est une annonce
satisfaisante maintenant qu'ils ont été
bloqués à plus de 57% et qui font des
rentrées d'argent que l'état n'avait pas
prévu je dirais que c'est tout bonus
pour lui donc un non dit que cette somme
d'argent qu'ils qu'il récupère à défaut
de le mettre peut-être de mettre du tout
l'entièreté dans les positions
écologique de peut-être aussi de le
mettre dans la poche des français qui
aujourd'hui subissent cette économie
trois fois et je tiens à rappeler que
ceux qui sont les premiers tributaire de
ces hausses de prix sont les français de
première cordée ceux qui ont déjà
souffert depuis deux ans ne serait-ce
que face au co vite pour tenir les rangs
pour tenir leur travail et pour aller
aussi se rendent au travail
aujourd'hui évidemment la question que
tout le monde doit vous posez
et que craint en premier lieu le
gouvernement cette reprise du mouvement
d'aidé gilet jaune aujourd'hui quel est
l'état d'esprit dans vos rangs en étant
ces mesures de manière fébrile pour pour
un girondin alors déjà je le répète
cette ce prix fixe cette particule
reprise reviennent retour les gilet
jaune ça n'existe pas ou vous êtes bien
placé et rt pour livre fréquemment
depuis deux ans qu'on en est au 150e
match des 6 4 vous êtes la meilleure
selon nos confrères d'europe 1 le
service central du renseignement étaient
mobilisés pour surveiller d'éventuels
reprise du mouvement des belges et des
jaunes je suis assez bien placé pour
savoir qu'on est surveillé
principalement ma personne en tous les
cas quand je me pointe sur parler ou
autres lieux lieu en france la crainte
elle est là pourquoi ils ont peur parce
qu'ils sont dans l'incapacité
aujourd'hui pouvoir répondre aux
français à défaut d'avoir peur aux
français à saint-lô nous autour d'une
table et si on débattre essayons
d'écouter les français qui eux ont des
propositions à faire pour améliorer leur
quotidien parce que force est de
constater que les politiques et le
gouvernement aujourd'hui sont hors sol
ils sont incapables d'apporter une
réponse à l'ensemble des citoyens en
colère pire que ça ils nous font des ddd
lois liberticides qui empêche d'autant
plus le lien social et les français de
pouvoir communiquer et peut-être fin
fait remonter l'information de ce
mal-être aujourd'hui dans ce pays il est
important que qu'on puisse installer un
débat que d'installer un climat de peur
parce que si ce qui se joue depuis deux
ans de d'une part et d'autre moi je suis
pas là pour faire peur je suis là pour
discuter les gilets jaunes ont des
propositions à faire on a des
revendications à mettre en place a
proposé il serait grand temps de les
écouter parce que ce sont aussi eux qui
qui qui qui construisent la france ait
pas que parce que il n'ya pas que les
vies les jeunes entendent bien entendu
alors j'en sois évidemment en direct le
fil des des annonces de jean castex nous
avons pris la décision d'une indemnité
inflation de 100 euros qui sera versée
100 euros un pas deux cents 200 euros
qui sera versée aux français qui gagnent
moins de 2000 euros net par mois gilles
casanova le cheix avions
décision d'une indemnité inflation oui
100 euros qui sera versée c'est une
indemnité dont on entendra les 780 euros
de budget une augmentation du budget sur
les carburants la fin de l'année les 680
euros donc on n'y est pas
oui ça va être encore l'usiné à gaz ont
tiré un des documents et avoir fait le
métier d'administrateur et sert à
remplir des documents pour pouvoir
bénéficier de cette somme donc voilà on
y est pas quoi qu'il arrive on est
encore en train de nous enfumer et les
français continueront ne pas être
content et là je pense que oui ils
peuvent continuer d'avoir peur parce que
la colère manifestement il ya moins de
personnes dans la rue sans faire le jeu
de mots mais quoi qu'il arrive la colère
elle est bien présente et 6 moules et à
défaut de
celle ci celle ci explose bac on essaye
de mettre en place des choses justement
pour éviter ce genre de problème j'ai
casanova contre vous écouter à la fois
les annonces de jean castex et jérôme
rodez est ce qu'il nous dit voilà c'est
pas parce que les jets les gens ne sont
pas dans la rue qui a pas de colère elle
est bien là c'est une colère que risque
qui risque fort pour emmanuel macron de
se retrouver dans les urnes en 2022
aurait grillé tous ses aspects le
premier aspect c'est que depuis 50 ans
toutes sortes de gouvernements de toutes
sortes de couleurs on pensait que donner
de l'argent avant l'élection allait
faire voter pour leur champion alors
cette en général moins cynique que cette
fois ci mais il ya toujours quelque
chose de ce genre là ça n'a jamais
fonctionné jamais on peut donner de
l'argent aux électeurs avant l'élection
il comprend bien que on lui reprendra
après donc ça ça ne marche pas le
deuxième aspect c'est celui-là colère le
problème de
faible mobilisation des gilets jaunes il
est lié au fait que lorsque le mouvement
a démarré il y avait une certaine
innocence sur ces ronds points il y
avait des personnes qui voulait
s'adresser au gouvernement en disant le
président le gouvernement ne comprennent
pas qu'il y a un malaise et il ne nous
entendent pas on va leur parler il va
comprendre ils vont prendre des mesures
ils savent maintenant que les mesures
qui ont été prises sont essentiellement
des mesures de répression à leur égard
et que ce n'est pas qu'on ne les entend
pas c'est qu'on a décidé de s'affronter
à eux sur le fond parce que c'est les
choix politiques que fait un
gouvernement que faire un président donc
voyant cela beaucoup de gens comprennent
bien que descendre dans la rue
aujourd'hui ça ne va pas
permettre d'obtenir une satisfaction
parce que c'est le premier gouvernement
depuis une cinquantaine d'années qui ne
négocient pas qui a très peu réagi par
rapport à des mobilisations et des
manifestations il n'a aucun parti
politique derrière dont il veut sauver
les élus je rappelle qu'il fait 2,2 pour
cent des inscrits et des exprimés aux
élections municipales chiffres ministère
de l'intérieur et selon les mêmes
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur il
fait trois et demi pour cent aux
élections des inscrits aux élections
régionales donc il n'a rien à perdre
avoir une politique de dureté
jeu se cassent taxes en actions qui vont
apprécier sa pensée 2000 euros à cette
fameuse indemnité inflation de 100 euros
qui sera donc versé à ces français qui
gagnent moins de 1000 euros il dit en
gros c'est le salaire médian des
français 36 millions de français
concernés c'est une
juste l'an vous jérôme rodriguez sachant
qu'avec 100 euros c'est vrai que ça va
être compliqué de
est ce que cette somme va la destination
des ménages publiée aussi les catégories
professionnelles la jeune discuter avec
un taxi qui sont fortement aussi impacté
par l'augmentation du gazoil tous les
proches de métier qui utilisent leur
véhicule sont passés en passant par les
ambulanciers ou autre
mais sont heureux
on est là on va faire du blabla pendant
une semaine on va vous parler de
pourcentage de ceux ci c'est simple 780
euros d'augmentation du budget carburant
à la fin de l'année pour une voiture
pour lequel vous ferez un plein de 50
litres par semaine on est à 780 euros ll
nous lâche son euro et encore pour
encore aller les chercher je pense
j'imagine qu'il faut remplir tout un tas
de condition modeste
vous je ne sais pas ce qu'il aurait été
plus juste il est clair qu'aujourd'hui
le compte n'y est pas on pourra nous
dire oui 36 millions multiplié par 100
ça fait tant de gros matches le compte
n'y est pas 100 euros ça va faire quoi
ça va faire deux pleins on en est à il
nous manque encore 50 plein pour que les
gens puissent aller travailler emmener
leurs gamins à l'école faire des courses
quand vous vivez en province vous faites
20 km pour les chercher un billet de 20
euros vous fait 22 autres kilomètres
pour les mettre votre plein d'essence
vous arrivez n'avait plus que 10 euros
hors taxes
c'est ça c'est du concret aujourd'hui il
faut arrêter de parler en pourcentage en
bla bla on parle euros aujourd'hui on
parle poche des français qui
malheureusement il y en a plus
aujourd'hui c'est plus le 15 du mois
quand quand les jets les gens qui sont
sortis aujourd'hui ça va être le 10 du
mois voir le 8 du mois et ça c'est plus
possible
jérôme brodier en vous remercier parce
que vous avez de voir filer
malheureusement en tout cas merci
d'avoir réagi à ces annonces de jean
castex le monde enfin pour vous je
casanova c'est justement cette crainte
de ce mouvement quand on écoute dire le
verrou mme rodriguez on se dit que c'est
quelque chose maintenant qu'ils risquent
de voile à se reproduire ce mouvement
aussi bien dans la rue et évidemment
c'est la question que vous posez tout à
l'heure dans les urnes parce que le
compte ne semble pas être en tout cas la
mesure présentée est une mesure
technocratique qui va vers l'échec son
volume n'est pas à la hauteur des
problèmes et en tant qu elle coûte cher
il y avait une autre méthode très simple
qui était une échelle mobile des taxes
qui fasse que le prix des carburants
reste le même à la pour le consommateur
la part des taxes diminuant d'autant que
augmenterait le prix du carburant lui
même c'est une méthode qui a été mis en
place il ya quelques années qui est
évidemment coûteuse tout est coûteux
mais au moins elle al'avantage que le
consommateur final à un prix qui ne
bouge pas mais pour des raisons
idéologiques liée à la force de
l'idéologie
écologiste pas les partis écologistes
mais une idéologie écologistes qui
touche très spécifiquement l'électorat
du président et du gouvernement actuel
il y à un refus de cette solution qui
ferait simple alors tout le masque à sap
est une vraie erreur pendant tout cas m
gouvernement macron ce soir
c'est possible mais il a déjà fait
tellement de choses maladroite qu'on a
l'impression que d'un certain point de
vue la coupe est déjà pleine elle
déborde merci beaucoup en tout cas à
vous j'ai le casanova également mercy
âgée ont brillé ce qui vient de nous
quitter pour un autre plateau télé voilà
en tout cas on vous avait pu réagir en
direct à ces annonces du premier
ministre merci à vous et avec cette
crise énergétique mondiale notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles on
revient nourrir les débats sur le vieux
continent l approche de la coop 26
comment trouver un juste équilibre pour
endiguer le réchauffement de la planète
l'onu tire aujourd'hui la sonnette
d'alarmé dans un rapport son inquiétude
la hausse dans les dix prochaines années
des investissements dans la production
de pétrole ou encore du gaz
selon les chercheurs du programme des
nations unies pour l'environnement la
production mondiale d'énergie fossile
durant les deux prochaines décennies
devraient être plus de deux fois
supérieure au niveau permettant de
limiter le réchauffement à 1,5 degré
celsius
limitation convenu dans le cadre de
l'accord de paris le 5 novembre 2016
l'étude pointe 15 grands pays
producteurs de combustibles fossiles qui
continuent d'apporter un soutien
politique important à la production de
ces sources d'énergie
d'après le rapport les gouvernements
hôtes orienter plus de 256 milliards
d'euros de nouveaux fonds vers les
activités liées aux combustibles
fossiles depuis le début de la pandémie
de coved 19 puisque vers les énergies
propres tendances qui promet de perdurer
tout le monde peut témoigner des effets
dévastateurs du changement climatique il
est encore temps de limiter le
réchauffement à long terme à 1,5 degré
celsius mais cette opportunité
s'amenuisent rapidement alors que la
coop 26 s'apprête à ouvrir ses portes en
écosse les scientifiques de l'onu
renouvellent leur appel à un changement
radical il est urgent que tous les
financeurs publics ainsi que les
financeurs privés y compris les banques
commerciales et les gestionnaires
d'actifs fasse passer leur financement
du charbon aux énergies renouvelables
afin de promouvoir la décarbonation
complète du secteur de l'électricité et
l'accès aux énergies renouvelables pour
tous selon les experts en climatologie
de l'onu le giec pour ne pas dépasser
une augmentation de 1,5 degrés les
émissions de deux doivent être réduite
de 45% dans le monde d'ici à 2030 par
rapport à 2010 le gasoil et l'essence en
passe de devenir des produits de luxe
ont presque avec cette flambée des prix
qui touche toute l'europe carburant d'un
côté gaz électricité de l'eau tradition
commence à devenir très salée pour les
ménages on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir dans son
édito est qu
[Musique]
un bon soir jacques merci d'être avec
nous un pour cette actualité brûlante
avec ses annonces de jean castex ce soir
on va essayer d'approfondir de de nous
comprendre davantage ces mécanismes
atouts font les les prix de l'énergie
tout d'abord à quoi ces onze sont
tendues alors effectivement et ce sont
des housses qui commence vraiment à
faire mal aux consommateurs qui commence
à faire mal et aux classes moyennes et
aux classes populaires alors c'est aux
700 dû à quoi effectivement il y à une
hausse des cours ya même une hausse des
coûts de production mais si on regarde
un petit peu rétrospectivement on voit
que cette hausse elle est bien plus
faible que celle qu'on avait connue il
ya quelques années que ce en 2007 en
2013 et donc en réalité ce qu'il ya
derrière ce sont faut le dire les
incohérences de la politique du
gouvernement et de la politique
énergétique de l'union européenne qui
font que justement battre sur l'ensemble
de ce dossier il ya malheureusement
énormément d'hypocrisie de la part des
politiques ça veut dire que quand les
prix n'ont pas ou en tant que cela alors
oui les prix ont augmenté les cours du
pétrole en particulier ont augmenté mais
effectivement vous avez raison de dire
c'est pas tant que cela et on peut voir
par exemple sur le graphique que ben on
est très en dessous alors je ne parle
même pas de ce qui s'est passé dans la
période
86 90 mais même nettement en dessous de
ce qui s'était passé de 2007 a grosso
modo 2013 aujourd'hui globalement on
serait revenu au niveau 2018 seulement
c'est parce que ressentent évidemment
les ménages c'est parce que ressent
l'automobiliste qui passe à la pompe et
on voit bien que là il ya un problème
alors ce graphique ne concerne que les
prix du pétrole jacques pourquoi alors
cette hausse des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité
alors en ce qui concerne le gaz ça c'est
un autre problème et là c'est
typiquement un problème de politique
européenne de réglementation européenne
au départ on avait ce qu'on appelait des
contrats à long terme alors ses contrats
long terme effectivement quand les prix
baisser vers sa vie etc ont payé un
petit peu plus cher que ce qu'on aurait
dû payer mais quand les prix montent et
et bien payés nettement moins cher et
puis bah voilà les les technocrates de
bruxelles on dit mais c'est pas du tout
logique d'abord un un contrat de long
terme eh bien ça vous bloque avec un
contractant dans dans le cadre de la
france et de l'europe c'était soit la
russie soit l'algérie et puis justement
ça empêche de faire des économies encore
faut-il que les prix ne remontent pas
donc on a démonté le système des
contrats de long terme on est passé à un
régime ou en fait le prix du gaz est
fixé sur des marchés journalier bon
c'est ce qu'on appelle en fait les
marchés spot et ça aboutit à quoi ça
aboutit à ce que le prix du gaz sont en
fait indexé sur le prix du pétrole alors
qu'il ne l'était pas il ya quinze ans où
il y avait un temps est donc le résultat
c'est que aujourd'hui ma comme les prix
du pétrole remontent et bien évidemment
le prix du gaz remontent massivement et
là c'est quand même extrêmement
important parce que le gaz passe et
c'est ce qu'on utilise pour se chauffer
c'est ce qu'on utilise pour faire la
cuisine et sa touche quand même un
nombre de gens tout à fait considérable
1 pour l'électricité alors pour
l'électricité il ya encore un autre
problème quand on regarde par exemple
techniquement d'ouvrir l'électricité
française c'est du nucléaire s'est très
largement du nucléaire et donc comme les
centrales sont amorties depuis longtemps
puisque maintenant le les centrales
elles ont entre 30 et pratiquement 50
ans un pour les pour les plus vielles
devrait payer
des sommes extrêmement faible sauf que
l'union européenne là encore est
intervenue et a dit on veut faire un
grand marché de l'électricité on veut
des monopolisé et privatiser les
systèmes électriques or pour faire un
grand marché il faut faire un prix si
vous voulez vous ne pouvez pas faire de
marché si dans chaque pays vous avez des
prix différents donc on a voulu faire un
prix unique à marché unique prix unique
et sur quoi on a indexé le prix de
l'électricité vous le donne en mille sur
le prix du gaz un résultat aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le consommateur français
alors c'est pas vrai pour des pays par
exemple comme l'allemagne qui ont
abandonné le nucléaire et qui donc sont
très dépendants ou du gaz ou du charbon
mais le consommateur français qui
auraient dû être protégé sans cette
politique européenne eh bien ils surent
paye son électricité à cause de cela il
ya également les taxes oui tout à fait
ah ça vous avez tout à fait raison la
part des taxes dans les prises des
carburants elle est tout à fait énorme
c'est d'ailleurs une tradition assez
français mais pas que il ya d'autres
pays où vous avez aussi des taxes très
importante et là on voit là il ya même
quelque chose qui est je dirais un petit
peu aberrant qui moi me me hérisse par
rapport à ce que je sais ce que j'avais
appris dans mes études s'ils voulaient
de droit fiscal vous payer une taxe sur
la taxe c'est à dire que vous avez sur
la tcp eux qui attaquent ce principal
sur les carburants vous avez une tva sur
la tcp eu un bon
résultat quand vous payez votre gazole
pour des gens qui par exemple du diesel
ou même chose si vous payez de l'essence
sans plomb à 0,95 et bien le prix du
carburant avec le raffinage c'est pas le
prix brut s'est dit c'est 30% du prix à
la pompe donc on voit qu'il y a là des
marges extrêmement importante et on
comprend pourquoi il ya beaucoup alors
que ce soit des candidats où que ce soit
même des gens de la majorité qui
s'adresse au gouvernement et qui disent
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut jouer de
manière à faire baisser le coût pour le
consommateur là manifestement ce n'est
pas l'option en tout cas qui a été
choisie on en a parlé à hasnon jacques
pourquoi vous parlez de l'hypocrisie
alors c'est quand même si vous voulez
une énorme hypocrisie parce que on voit
bien que la dynamique actuelle des prix
de tous les carburants alors que ce soit
le pétrole fait que ce soit les sens que
ce soit le gard où que ce soit
l'électricité tout ça c'est de l'énergie
globalement que tous ces prix sont
aujourd'hui dominé par une dynamique qui
est la dynamique de privatisation et de
déréglementation qu'a voulu impulser
l'union européenne au nom justement de
la construction d'un grand marché unique
de l'énergie et que les gouvernements
français c'est pas que la faute à
bruxelles à il faut être honnête à dieu
que les gouvernements français se sont
précipités pour faire appliquer on a
privatisé gaz de france on a privatisé
une partie de dr bref aujourd'hui vous
avez des politiques qui lève les bras au
ciel et qui disent ah oui c'est
impossible les français payent leur
énergie trop cher ça vaut un problème
mais il fallait y penser plus tôt il
fallait y penser plus tôt parce que nous
sommes d'assez nombreux économistes qui
avons dit cette logique de privatisation
cette logique de déréglementation elle a
été mise en place aux états unis en
californie il ya vingt ans de cela et ça
avait abouti à des hausses massives du
prix de l'énergie on savait que c'était
ça qu'il y avait dans les cartons avec
cette déréglementation et 7
démonopolisation peut dire du marché
alors bien sûr maintenant on va penser à
des mesures que ce soit le chèque
énergie ou qu'on l'appelle autrement que
ce soit des blocages de prix ces
blocages de prix on comprend bien que
sauf à changer la réglementation ils ne
pourront durer que six mois maintenant
pas plus voir en 2008
a fait voir d'après ce que j'ai entendu
il n'a pas exclu que cilaos continuer à
ce rythme sur 2022 eh bien on
regarderait du côté de la structure
fiscale c'est-à-dire du poids des taxes
sur les carburants mais tout cela
j'utilise une expression populaire c'est
cautère sur jambe de bois ce n'est qu'un
palliatif en fête est donc là il ya une
vraie hypocrisie des politiques qui
consiste à ne pas choisir de politique
énergétique claire ne pas s'y tenir et
après évidemment d'en déplorer les
effets bref je vais pas faire mon
bossuet mais vous savez ces gens qui se
lamentent sur des faits dont ils
chérissent les causes eh bien nous
sommes exactement dans cette situation
sur les prix d'énergie merci jacques
sapir on rappelle les deux principales
annonces du premier ministre ce soir le
blocage les prix du gaz et sur toute
l'année 2022 également une indemnité en
fassions 200 euros qui sera versée aux
français de manière automatique qui
viennent moins de 2000 euros net par
mois ou merci à vous
et la crise des énergies sur le vieux
continent l'un des dossiers en
discussion jusqu'à demain également
sommet de bruxelles sur la table les
tensions entre bruxelles et varsovie la
pologne met en cause la primauté du
droit européen sur son droit national ce
qui me plaît évidemment pas a lieu
aujourd'hui les dirigeants des
vingt-sept ont affiché leur fermeté face
à ces propos mais aussi tendu la main à
varsovie sébastien zaba le sujet ne
devait pas figurer au programme de ce
sommet mais des explications étaient
nécessaires la relation entre la pologne
et l'union européenne s'est rapidement
dégradée ces dernières semaines après
que le tribunal constitutionnel polonais
a jugé certains articles des traités
européens
incompatible avec la constitution
nationale déclenchant ainsi l'ire de
bruxelles le premier ministre polonais
s'est montré ferme en arrivant au sommet
tout en se disant ouvert au dialogue
nous n'agirons pas sous la pression du
chantage nous sommes prêts au dialogue
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
l'élargissement constant des compétences
mais nous discuterons bien sûr de la
manière de résoudre les différends
actuels dans un esprit de compromis et
de
dialogue si mateusz moravie et ce qui
parle de chantage c'est parce que la
commission européenne a bloqué les 36
milliards d'euros destiné à son pays
dans le cadre du plan de relance de
bruxelles une décision vivement dénoncée
par le premier ministre polonais ce
mardi réponse de la présidente de la
commission européenne ursula von der
leyen la commission ne restera pas les
bras croisés laissant deviner de
possibles sanctions à venir en revanche
lui aussi présent ce jeudi pour le
sommet le premier ministre hongrois
viktor orban on n'est pas convaincu de
l'utilité des sanctions contre la
pologne dont il est un allié la pologne
le meilleur pays d'europe aucune
sanction n'est nécessaire c'est ridicule
la primauté du droit européen ne figure
pas du tout dans le traité l'union
européenne a donc la primauté là où elle
a des compétences
la question porte sur les compétences et
ce qui se passe ici c'est que les
institutions européennes qu'on tourne
régulièrement les droits des parlements
et des gouvernements nationaux et
modifie le traité sans avoir aucune
autorité légitime pour le faire les
polonais ont donc raison à la demande de
certains pays ce dossier chaud de
l'actualité européenne a été
effectivement abordé ce jeudi lors de la
réunion du conseil européen mais aucune
conclusion ni décisions ne sont attendus
l'allemagne soucieuse de préserver une
cohésion avec ses homologues européens a
rappelé l'importance de l'état de droit
nous cherchons à faire respecter l'état
de droit par le biais de la procédure
actuelle de rupture de contrat contre la
pologne l'état de droit est un pilier
essentiel de l'union européenne d'autre
part nous devons trouver des moyens et
des possibilités de travailler ensemble
car une cascade de litiges juridiques
devant la cour de justice européenne
n'est pas une solution aux problèmes si
nous voulons croire en l'état de droit
problème
la commission européenne disposent
d'autres moyens de pression contre
varsovie mais la plupart des états
membres prônant un apaisement des
tensions et les conclusions de la cour
de justice de l'union européenne avant
de faire appel à des outils plus
persuasifs
dans le reste d'actualité cannes banque
française dans le viseur du fisc la
raison une potentielle fraude au
dividende qui aurait fait perdre 30 3
milliards d'euros à l'état français en
20 ans révélation faite par un
consortium de médias internationaux dont
le monde ce sont ces médias qui avaient
mis en lumière en 2018 l'ampleur en
europe du coucou pratiques financières
controversé qui a coûté plus de 50
milliards d'euros en quinze ans à
plusieurs états de l'ue ce même
contentieux qui vient d'actualiser les
chiffres estelle farges
comme comme vous n'avez peut-être jamais
entendu parler de cette pratique mais
dans le monde de la finance elle est
très bien connu il s'agit d'un mécanisme
destiné aux investisseurs étrangers et
qui leur permet d'éviter les taxations
de dividendes autrement dit lorsqu'un
investisseurs étrangers achètent des
parts d'une entreprise française cotée
en bourse il doit s'acquitter de l'impôt
sur les dividendes perçus grâce à des
montages financiers le coucou nous
permet tout simplement d'échapper à cet
impôt notamment à l'aide des banques en
2018 un consortium de 16 médias avait
publié une enquête intitulée comme x
files il y révélait notamment que le
coucou m'avait coûté 50 milliards
d'euros en quinze ans à plusieurs états
de l'ue eux c'était sans compter sur une
petite actualisation des chiffres ainsi
ce ne serait pas moins de 150 milliards
d'euros qui auraient échappé au fisc de
plusieurs pays européens en 20 ans dont
la france c'est le plus grand braquage
fiscale de l'histoire trois ans après la
publication des comics files un
consortium international de journalistes
dirigé par correctives montre comment
les contribuables du monde entier ont
été escroqués 250 milliards d'euros
ainsi pour la france cette pratique a
engendré une perte de revenus de 33,4
milliards d'euros c'est par exemple plus
que les 30 milliards alloués au plan
france 2030 à 28,5 milliards pour
l'allemagne ou encore 27 milliards
d'euros pour les pays bas dans
l'hexagone quatre banques sont dans le
viseur des autorités financières selon
le quotidien le monde bnp paribas la
société générale natixis et le crédit
agricole à travers l'une de ses filiales
le journal révèle que l'administration
fiscale a commencé à s'intéresser au
coupe-coupe dès 2017 avant donc les
révélations de l'enquète du consortium
de journalistes le parquet national
financier a indiqué au monde qu'un
dossier est actif mais la plupart des
autres partis n'ont fait aucun
commentaire
toujours est il que si l' enquête
aboutit des redressements fiscaux
pourraient tomber encore faut-il non
seulement prouver le caractère illégal
des opérations s de la fraude ou de
l'optimisation fiscale et surtout que le
seul motif de ces opérations est de
tromper le fisc et donc d'échapper à
l'emploi il reste un défi de taille pour
l'administration fiscale prouver que
cette optimisation fiscale est illégal
ce que contestent les banques
incriminées en effet prises
individuellement les opérations
constituant le com com prêter acheter ou
vendre des actions pour une courte durée
sont légales pour les contester les
inspecteurs de bercy sont obligés
d'établir que l'ensemble de la manoeuvre
un motif principalement fiscale dans
certains pays de l'ue ont fait des
efforts ont récemment été fait pour
légiférer sur le coup comme c'est le
canot damman en finlande et en allemagne
en france l'assemblée nationale avait
voté une réforme entrée en vigueur en
juillet 2019 pour lutter contre ces
mécanismes financiers mais selon le
monde le dispositif a été affaiblie par
la majorité au prétexte d'un nettoyage
juridique seuls les montages financiers
les plus simples ont été interdits ce
qui permet donc aux banques de les
contourner
et direction à présent les états unis où
donald trump a décidé de lancer son
propre réseau social une plateforme de
l'ancien président américain qui devrait
voir le jour au premier trimestre 2001
22 on en parle avec à notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnet
bonsoir c'est là que sait-on de ce
nouveau réseau social
et bien c'est une plate forme qui a été
intitulé truth sochaux laissé selon le
communiqué publié ce mercredi par les
équipes de même trump par réseau social
qui aura pour but de donner la parole à
tous mais c'est aussi et surtout un
moyen pour l'ancien locataire de la
maison blanche de tenter de s'opposer
aux géants du secteur twitter et
facebook pour ne citer qu'eux qui ont
rappelle ont banni les comptes officiels
de donald trump suite aux événements du
6 janvier au capitole d'ailleurs il en
est question dans le communiqué qui a
été publié hier et kt et
j'ai créé trousses sociale et mtg trump
médias n technology group pour résister
à la tyrannie des géants de la tech nous
vivons dans un monde où les taliban ou
une énorme présence sur twitter et
pourtant votre président américain
préféré a été réduit au silence c'est
inacceptable alors on sait que la
politique de modération des géants du
secteur est souvent remise en question
beaucoup parlent de censure c'est le cas
par exemple de donald trump et il faut
rappeler que l'ancien président a déposé
deux plaintes ces dernières semaines
pour tenter de récupérer assez compte
sur twitter et sur facebook où il avait
accumulé des millions d'abonnés en ce
moment c'est par le biais de communiqués
qu'il publie de manière assez régulière
que donald trump s'adresse à ses
partisans mais évidemment il ya une
portée beaucoup moins importante qu'à
l'époque où il pouvait se contenter d'un
tweet pour s'adresser au plus grand
nombre il faut aussi rappeler qu'au mois
de mai dernier donald trump avait tenté
de lancer un blog mais il n'y a pas
vraiment eu le succès escompté et la
page a été fermée depuis alors cette
fois c'est un projet plus ambitieux qui
devrait voir le jour plus ambitieux
notamment financièrement puisque trump
va s'associer avec une autre entreprise
pour créer un groupe qui serait valorisé
selon les estimations à 1,7 milliard de
dollars et il faut noter qu'en plus d'un
réseau social il y aura aussi une
plateforme de vidéo à la demande qui va
être lancée avec des contenus non roque
selon le communiqué qui a donc été
publié ce mercredi tous ces services
devraient être disponibles d'ici le
premier trimestre 2001 22 il va donc
falloir attendre encore un petit peu
pour se connecter à l'application de
donald trump merci thomas bonnet en
direct de washington et pour approfondir
nous sommes avec nicolas conc'air
porte-parole des républicaines sont
versys france partisans donc ça de
donald trump bonsoir nicolas conc'air
merci d'être avec nous donald trump qui
annonce donc le lancement de son propre
réseau social pour dit il résister face
à la tyrannie des géants des
technologies c est un projet très très
ambitieux
ma fille est assurément on peut on
pouvait pas attendre au moins de sa de
trump là il ya un vrai projet avec des
grosses ambitions qui vont pouvoir être
lancées à l'horizon 2022 c'est pas
anodin ça arrive lors d'une année
charnière une année d'élection et on
peut vraiment compter à ce que ça puisse
permettra à 32 remobiliser un toute sa
base et deux portes et un peu au devant
de la scène et sans qu'un seul quelques
heures sans shadowbane toutes ces
technologies toutes ces techniques qui
sont pratiqués par les géants de la
silicon valley pour passer a couvert les
voies les conservateurs de permettre à
donald trump et au candidat républicain
de porter à au plus grand nombre leur
leurs voix et leurs promesses de
campagne donc effectivement on l'avait
dit une manière de revenir est de
clairement peser politiquement ont lancé
un précédent
alors ça a été un secret pour personne
dès qu'il a quitté la maison blanche il
avait à souhait et on pouvait compter
sur lui pour qu'il soit mobilisée et
qu'ils puissent continuer à jouer en
politique que ce soit de manière
politicienne ou métapolitique je pense
que ceux qui pensaient qu'il allait
profiter d'une retraite en jouant au
golf amara la gaule ont peut-être parlé
un peu trop rapidement et on voit que yo
là il ne manque pas de projets de
soutenir des candidats républicains et
de continuer à lancer cette dynamique
qui était initialement michael bates
guen qui passe maintenant c'est yves
america vu vu la gestion déplorable de
l'administration actuelle
c'est follow the shoes c'est ce qu'on
peut lire sur la page de garde
nouveau futur un réseau social ça veut
dire on que chacun aura sa vérité
facebook d'un côté donald trump de
l'autre
alors c'est à dire que d'une part à ces
réseaux sociaux se sont vraiment arrogé
un droit de dicter la fugue beau temps
de faire les élections s'ils le
voulaient en modérant des différents
contenus profitant vraiment de niche de
traitement de faveur qui leur a été
attribué à savoir qu'ils n'étaient pas
tenus responsables ces propos alors
qu'il faisait de la modération il
passait donc deux plateformes à éditeurs
et de ska dans ce cas là ils devraient
être tenues redevable est responsable
des propos qui publiaient sur leurs
plateformes maintenant l'idée c'est
surtout de pouvoir permettre à une
liberté d'expression et de ne pas passer
à couvert à plus forte raison un ancien
président de la république ainsi que
voilà tout
l'opinion de la moitié du peuple
américain
avait évoqué aussi un ca fournira
également un service de vidéo à la
demande et des bosses caste non aucun
comment réagit-on chez les républicains
certaines
demandes dans une parmi les partisans de
donald trump
alors c'est intéressant ce que cette
demande elle va bien au delà de la base
de 30 c'est vraiment le bon sens qui est
fait appel à cette décision à ce choix
de modifier un petit peu les catalogues
des programmations pas les nommer mais
de sega femme qui est vraiment cherche à
pousser un calendrier idéologique en
modérant les contenus et on va jusqu'à
supprimer des dessins animés des
classiques des veaux jeunesse des
aristochats au passage pour quelques
offense ou parce que les enfants
seraient pas en mesure de saisir les
messages ou la portée de ses dessins
animés on a ça en passant tout à fait à
côté de l'aspect ludique entertainment
qui va être remis au coeur de cette
offre qui sera qui sera mise mise mise
au public le fait c'est quand même
trempe le dit si bien cinq de gauche
est donc jeu pour le traduire tout ce
qui vit par work tourner en jus de
boudin pour rester polie et et le voilà
les elle est allée les sondages les les
participations le nombre de membres de
toutes les plateformes va en diminuant
parce que justement ils souscrivent 3
cet agenda walk qui est loin de d'être
du goût de tous les abonnés de ces
plateformes en mai dernier à l'ancien
président avait fait son retour sous la
forme d'un site de
mais ça n'a pas trop pris ça veut dire
aujourd'hui clairement qu'ils aient
besoin de de remobiliser ses partisans
donald trump ils sont aussi nombreux
qu'avant
aujourd'hui on est en train de parler
d'une affaire qui est pas loin d'avoir
signé les deux milliards de dollars donc
ça montre vraiment les ambitions et que
les investisseurs vont se ranger
derrière parce qu'ils croient dans le
pouvoir l'influencé le charisme et la
base du camp républicain qui sera prêt à
soutenir cette idée indépendamment de la
personne qui a derrière l'idée c'est ils
ont fait confiance maintenant le courant
est monté il ya une dynamique derrière
on est à une année charnière comme je le
disais avec les élections de mid-term de
mi mandat qui auront lieu en 2022 et il
ya fort à croire que cette dynamique va
être bénéfique fructueuse et qu'elle
permettra d'avoir un vrai succès
électoral lors des prochaines élections
merci beaucoup nicolas conc'air d'avoir
été avec nos porte-paroles républicaine
overseas france merci d'être avec nous
au deuxième jour de sa tournée en
amérique latine le chef de la diplomatie
américaine fait l'éloge de son allié
colombien anthony blinken salue ce
qu'ils considèrent comme un modèle de
gestion des migrants près de deux
millions de personnes se sont réfugiées
en colombie pour fuir le venezuela
voisin des états unis et la colombie
main dans la main pour s'opposer au
gouvernement de nicolás maduro des
explications de juliette lamy
après l'équateur anthony blinken
continue sa tournée sud américaine
ce mercredi il a été reçu par le
président colombien ivan du quai à
bogota objectif trouver des solutions
pour lutter contre l'insécurité en
amérique latine mais surtout évoqué les
questions migratoires un sujet essentiel
pour le secrétaire d'état américain
puisqu'il constitue l'un des défis
majeurs du continent
nous reconnaissons tous deux que le défi
migratoire sans précédent auxquels nous
sommes confrontés dans notre hémisphère
nécessite une coopération et une
coordination régionale est une
responsabilité partagée
c'est l'objet du travail que nous
faisons ensemble et je pense que nous
aurons des mesures concrètes à annoncer
pour relever ce défi plus tard dans la
journée
de son côté le président colombien a
tenu à remercier les etats-unis d'avoir
rapidement débloqué des fonds destinés à
ces enjeux migratoires mais il a surtout
évoqué la migration provenant du
venezuela car la colombie est devenue un
point de passage pour des milliers
d'haïtiens de cubains et de vénézuéliens
qui veulent se diriger vers les états
unis pour tenter de répondre à ce
problème le président du quai a lancé
cette année un plan de régularisation de
statut pour près d'un million de
déneiger lien sans papiers
[Musique]
je pense que la crise migratoire est
plus compliquée du monde qui se déroule
à lieu de cette région et c'est sans
doute la crise migratoire vénézuélienne
nous avons vu plus de 5 millions de
personnes quittaient le pays les eaux
gelées sans excès la nourriture et aux
médicaments et se vend dans différents
pays à la recherche d'opportunités nous
avons accueilli en colombie près de 1
million 8 de migrants venus de liens
nous avons créé un cadeau politique pour
faire face à cette situation très
compliquée
les tensions récurrentes entre la
colombie et le venezuela depuis 2015 ont
entraîné la fermeture de la frontière
entre les deux pays en 2019 lorsque la
colombie et une cinquantaine d'autres
pays ont reconnu le dirigeant
d'opposition juan garrido comme
président par intérim
caracas a totalement rompu ses relations
avec bogota
mais récemment les deux pays ont annoncé
la réouverture de leur frontière
terrestre principalement pour des
raisons commerciales une tentative de
réchauffement qui pour l'heure reste en
suspens
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du vote à l'assemblée
nationale d'un amendement en première
lecture qui permet aux chefs
d'établissements des collèges et lycées
nous connaître le statut vaccinal
des élèves su ce qu'ils aient suscité
polémiques il surprend proviseur et
syndicats qui disent même pas on
éprouvait le besoin l'opposition elle
dénonce une violation inacceptable du
secret médical
[Musique]
vous comment abordez vous cette épreuve
vous êtes vous rendu au procès je suis
allé aux premières auditions du procès
j'ai trouvé vraiment que le monde
finalement été formés de gens
merveilleux et de aidé de jean ignoble
en fait vous ne savez pas comment votre
fils est mort vous devez enquêter sur
tout et vous confronter ils étaient ni
sur la liste des morts nés sur l'île des
blessés ni ride et hopitalisé il était
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur est la
couleur seront là jusqu'à ma mort
je
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte c'est du séparatisme
[Musique]
il ya eu celle et panama peppers les
paradise peppers place aujourd'hui aux
pandora peppers la plupart de ces de ces
opérations sont en fait parfaitement
légale y a rien de nouveau sous le
soleil on révèle effectivement un
système dans lequel il ya probablement
enfin incontestablement de plus en plus
de fuite devant l'impôt de plus en plus
de correction et de plus en plus de
difficulté des gouvernements avoir un
brin de contrôle sur ces masses d'argent
et qui circulent on pourrait simplement
arrêté au-delà ware ou dans d'autres
états comme ça de permettre ces
fonctionnements et c'est blanchiment ce
que vous pensez sérieusement que demain
le dakota du sud va arrêter ses
pratiques et qu'on va lui faire arrêter
ces pratiques non pas du tout
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche extrêmement
tous les peu moins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la communication emmanuel macron aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
tik tok est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont le désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus que nesc justement c'est une
nouvelle forme de communication assez
verticale utiliser des influenceurs pour
moissac hommes politiques personnelles
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme si
son travail en notre nom pour nous est
dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
il est 21 heures merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire se dirige-t-on vers
du secret médical à l'école française le
vote à l'assemblée nationale d'un
amendement en première lecture qui
permet aux chefs d'établissements des
collèges et lycées de connaître le
statut vaccinal des élèves suscite la
polémique
une surprend proviseur et syndicats qui
disent ne pas en éprouver le besoin
l'opposition dénonce une violation
inacceptable du secret médical
et vous est-ce que ça vous choque vous
pouvez réagir sur notre compte et des
grammaires t france
la possibilité d'avoir recours au pass
annie terre jusqu'en juillet 2022 a donc
été validé par les députés un projet de
loi adopté avec seulement dix voix
d'écart un amendement dont on vient de
parler qui attire particulièrement
l'attention concerne donc le statut
vaccinal des élèves mais suscite la
polémique
les précisions de solenn gaudin
un amendement passé jusqu'ici inaperçu
objectifs du gouvernement
faciliter le dépistage et la vaccination
contre le coc u19 à l'école en
permettant aux directeurs
d'établissement de savoir si les élèves
sont vaccinés contre le corona virus
s'ils voulaient proposer de permettre
aux directeurs d'établissement de faire
une saisine de l'assurance maladie sur
la base des élèves qui sont concernés
pour que la par l'intermédiaire de
l'assurance maladie il puisse connaître
le statut vaccinal des élèves et ainsi
pouvoir appliquer ces protocoles éviter
les fermetures des classes un texte qui
a donné lieu à des débats houleux au
palais bourbon jusque dans les rangs de
la majorité de temmerman faire passer
une telle mesure qui violent les
questions de secret médical et qui fait
porter une telle responsabilité sur le
poids des chefs d'été sur les épaules
des chefs d'établissement c'est vraiment
cavaliers comme méthode on emporte au
sein de l'enceinte de l'école en débat
qu'il n'y a pas sa place pourquoi
mettre fin un principe fondamental qui
est celui du secret médical au sein de
l'école avec cet amendement la crainte
que la levée du secret médical à l'école
ne se pérennise malgré ses protestations
le texte a été adopté qui est pour
keycorp par une assemblée très divisée
la validation de cette mesure s'est joué
à dix voix près mais du côté des parents
d'élèves ça ne passe pas aujourd'hui les
vaccins qui sont obligatoires sont au
nombre de 11 si la copie de 19 ans
faisant pas partie si la levée médical
levée du secret médical doit être fait
ça doit être dans ces conditions et
uniquement dans ce cadre là un texte qui
fait débat jusqu'à la sortie de l'école
ce jeudi du coup les enfants dont les
parents diront non pourront pas
forcément avoir accès aux sorties
sortie piscine notamment des choses
comme ça s'il s'agit des anciens vaccin
qui aura été prouvée
et avec lesquels on a suffisamment de
recul que même nous les adultes
avant eu ça y'a pas de soucis mais par
contre si ça concerne le vaccin qu'ovide
19 je ne suis pas d'accord il suffit
juste que le vaccin soit
obligatoire pour tous et la question se
posera même plus quoi et dans 10 ans
n'aura même plus cette question cette
loi doit encore être passés au crible
par le sénat
son vote est prévu jeudi prochain est
cette possibilité d'accéder au statut
vaccinal de leurs élèves est ce une
mesure de bon sens comme se défend la
république en marche une violation du
secret médical
inacceptables comme le dénonce de
nombreuses voix dans l'opposition
et vous qu'en pensez vous ça vous choque
on attend toujours vos réactions sur
notre compte et les grammaires t france
qui ont déjà été nombreuses tout au long
de la journée place en tout cas à notre
décryptage
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler sylvie magne
vous êtes infirmières scolaires en
loire-atlantique secrétaire adjoint du
syndicat national des infirmières
conseillère de santé également du snics
fsu à vos côtés frédéric sinclair
éditorialiste politique pour l'éclairage
justement politique sur ces actions du
gouvernement en la matière bonsoir à
tous les deux alors désormais un bientôt
en tout cas puisque là on en est à la
première lecture un proviseur saura si
un élève est vaccinée ou pas ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ont été très inspiré
aujourd'hui comme abdoullah par exemple
est très remonté mais où va-t-on vers un
flicage généralisé je crois il faut
stopper cet élan sinon on va vers la
dictature même colère chez liliane
scandaleux l'émission d'écoles libres
l'enseignement et rien d'autre ce n'est
pas un lieu de soins surtout pour les
enfants en bonne santé et n'ont concerné
par le cos vide s'ils me magnan un
flicage vous partager ce sentiment de
colère
en tout cas on partage un sentiment de
d'étonnement et d'inquiétude ce qui nous
préoccupe beaucoup en tout cas au
snics-fsu c'est de considérer que les
parents menthe et qui ça ça s'apparente
pour nous finalement à une rupture de
confiance et à une position assez
agressif vis-à-vis des familles et des
élèves et c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
observe au quotidien dans les
établissements jusqu'à présent les
familles ont toujours fait preuve d'une
grande bonne volonté les familles
d'ailleurs comme la communauté éducative
et principalement les élèves aussi dans
la dans la manière dont ils l'ont
appliqué toutes les injonctions et
toutes les demandes qui ont été mises en
place depuis déjà presque presque deux
ans on a fait confiance aux familles
quand il s'est agi de garder l'école
ouverte on a obtenu leur adhésion à
toutes les mesures y avait une dynamique
porteuse y avait du sens y avait avait
des valeurs autour de ça et venir la
rompre cette espèce de pacte qu'on avait
avec eux
effectivement nous ce n'est que ces
faits si on retrouve ça on trouve ça
préoccupant pour un bénéfice risque
voilà deux qui reste sans doute à
démontrer
frédéric saint clair on entend ces
minima ne des secours voilà et est très
solide c'est que onze en a beaucoup
demandé la cbi mal on parle de ce pacte
de confiance avec les parents mais cet
amendement il rend dans une loi plus
large le pas salutaire qui a encore
prolongé ce sentiment de voile a joué le
jeu et c'est peut-être la mesure de trop
les rares politiques
en réalité j'aurais aimé vous dire
qu'effectivement c'est la mesure de trop
et c'est l'erreur politique de troubles
mais ce n'est pas le cas parce qu'on
reste dans ce pays pour une raison qui
est complètement incompréhensible dans
une forme de d'hystérie qui a saisi à la
fois le corps le corps politique le lait
français j'allais dire dans leur grande
majorité qui soutiennent ce principe du
pass sanitaires et puis surtout le
gouvernement et puis les instances de
régulation sert les instances de
protection des libertés fondamentales
que sont le conseil d'état et le conseil
constitutionnel qui ont voté comme un
seul homme le pass and i ter en juillet
dernier donc si on veut comprendre ce
qui est en train de se passer il faut
être comme vous l'avez fait faire deux
pas en arrière revenir au mois de
juillet comprend que cette quatrième
vague qui a flambé comme aucune
auparavant a saisi le gouvernement et
l'a mis en état hystérique et donc c'est
pour ça que cette violence faite aux
libertés fondamentales a été si soudaine
et si brutale et ça inquiète et
manifestement le conseil d'état et le
conseil constitutionnel qui ont dit
effectivement il ya un gros risque et
donc il faut valider cet empiètement sur
les libertés est cette discrimination
entre deux catégories de français ceux
qui sont vaccinés et qui pourront à d
accéder à tous les endroits de la
société publique puis ceux qui ne le
sont pas et qui ne pourront pas
en fin de compte le malaise qui se
créent par rapport à ces discriminations
et à cette espèce d'empressement du
gouvernement vouloir bien faire en
accumulant les lois en prolongeant pour
en parler un peu plus mais tout ça est
basé sur quoi sur une vérité médicale
révélé par le conseil scientifique
en tout cas prétendument révélée et on
sait aujourd'hui qu'il ay à division
dans le corps médical c'est à dire qu'
on n'est pas d'accord tous les médecins
le montre on n'est pas d'accord sur sur
un toute hâte détail par rapport à ce
vaccin par rapport aux bénéfices risques
et donc il ya aujourd'hui un problème
politique qui est appuyée sur une
incertitude médical et c'est ça le noeud
du problème il faut bien il faut bien
comprendre que tant qu'on n'aura pas
réussi à mettre au clair ce qu'est ce
vaccin est ce qui n'est pas acquis il
protège et pour qui le risque est plus
grand que le bénéfice et c'est le cas
pour les enfants et bien dans ce cas là
on n'arrivera pas à tomber d'accord et
aujourd'hui finalement le gouvernement
touche du doigt c'est qui est le plus
précieux pour les parents que j'allais
dire les frontières le général c'est
l'institution scolaire et puis c'est
c'est les enfants de qui va falloir je
pense que le gouvernement prenne la
mesure de ce qu'il est en train de
mettre en place parce qu'il est possible
qu effectivement à terme c'est à dire
que si le l'épidémie venait à se calmer
comme on l'espère tous et si cette
petite résurgence qu'on a vue
dernièrement ne prenez pas plus
d'ampleur il est possible qu
effectivement les nombres de personnes
qui descendent dans la rue pour protéger
l'intégrité physique des enfants et ce
sanctuaire que l'école soit beaucoup
plus massif que ce qu'on a pu voir
pendant l'été alors la république en
marche entre se défend aujourd'hui
je
pour aurore bergé un porte parole de
l'ars m objectif est tout simplement de
faciliter l'organisation de campagnes de
dépistage et vaccination d'organiser des
conditions d'enseignement permettant de
prévenir les risques de propagation du
virus et donc in fine et les fermetures
de classes elle rajoute aura en berger
c'est une mesure de bon sens si l'imam
sauf que voilà tout le monde ne l'entend
pas de cette oreille cette mesure de bon
sens
ces jeux c'est une mesure peut dire que
c'est une mesure de bon sens alors que
depuis la rentrée scolaire l'école est
ouverte et que tout fonctionne plutôt
correctement les chefs d'établissement
ne sont pas particulièrement
demandeurs de ce type de mesure et ils
ne disent pas rencontré de difficultés
particulières en tout cas dans la
récupération
des informations qui sont nécessaires en
4k positif moi ça en tout cas ça nous
fait penser nous à la mise en place du
pass sanitaires à l'école j'ai plus ou
moins à plus ou moins long terme et est
peut-être plus à
un espèce de parapluies qu'on ouvrirait
pour pour cacher la capacité de l'état à
mettre vraiment en oeuvre des moyens
pour sécuriser l'espace scolaire
ça fait plusieurs mois qu'au niveau du
snics fsu on dit que pour ne pas fermer
de classes pour ne pas enlever des
enfants de l'école même quand il ya un
cas positif il serait bienvenu de
pouvoir développer développer les
équipes mobiles pour faire des tests et
pouvoir savoir assez rapidement
quels sont les enfants qui doivent
rester chez eux plutôt que de fermer des
classes sauf que pour faire ça il faut y
mettre les moyens et ne pas tabler
uniquement sur les personnels de santé
de l'éducation nationale qui ne sont
déjà pas suffisamment nombreux pour
assumer leurs missions il faudrait aussi
que les familles puissent être
responsabilisés après tout ce sont les
premiers éducateurs de leurs enfants
une famille qui s'est
avoir pris un contact avec quelqu'un de
positif
pourrait très bien faire passer un test
naso pharyngé ou un test salivaire à
l'enfant avant de le ramener à l'école
il ya tout un tas de mesures qui
pourraient être mises en oeuvre et qui
serait sans doute moins moins inquiétant
en termes de libertés que cette levée du
secret médical on lève aujourd'hui pour
pour cette vaccination on lèvera
pourquoi demain je je trouve que c'est
quelque chose qui est préoccupant et qui
dit des choses sur la société en ce
moment et je partage assez ce que ce que
l'autre intervenant disait sur une
espèce de frénésie qui s'est emparée
avec une panique de voir ressurgir une
quatrième une cinquième vague alors
qu'on voit dans les faits que ça n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui en tout cas vous
êtes nombreux à réagir à des instants gb
gbg il faut poser la question du
pourquoi faire les directeurs d'école
n'étant pas des médecins à quoi
peut-être leur être utile une telle
information purement médical à
discriminer intimidé à punir
effectivement la question des menus pour
quoi frédéric saint clair on a écouté le
développement de souliman mais en fait
le scandale n'était pas plutôt de
pousser les enfants aussi jeunes à la
vaccination est ce que ça c'est pas tout
simplement voilà l'aboutissement de ce
qu'on avait demandé aux enfants quoi
qu'il arrive de deux les contraintes
d'une certaine manière de toute manière
à se faire vacciner sont peine de ne pas
être accepté dans des clubs de foot dans
des clubs de danse de toute manière il
n'avait pas le choix la le gouvernement
assume et va au bout de sa logique c'est
exactement ça le gouvernement assume
levato bout de sa logique parce qu'il
sait que majoritairement cette hystérie
collective dont je parlais tout à
l'heure a saisi suffisamment de français
qu'il continue d'être favorable
aujourd'hui on passe sanitaire ça ne
sera pas le cas je fais le pari 1 ça ne
sera pas le cas dans l'est dans les
décennies à venir on regardera
rétrospectivement cette séquence là et
on rendra raison à tous ceux justice a
on rendra justice à tous ceux qui qui se
sont battus contre je parle bien du
passani terre et pas du vaccin il s'agit
pas d'être anti fax ici on parle
vraiment d'un problème politique un
problème d'amateurisme politique et un
problème d'hystérie qui consista à
instrumentaliser différentes catégories
de la population et les libertés
fondamentales pour parvenir à des fins
de régulation sociale donc en deux mots
ça signifie quoi ça signifie que sur les
enfants on sait très bien depuis le
début que premièrement les cas graves
sont extrêmement rares et que quand ils
sont quand les enfants sont contaminés
le
la contamination des autres enfants et
des adultes et je peux en témoigner
parce que j'ai vécu avec ma fille est
loin d'être évidente donc
fondamentalement la vaccination imposer
aux enfants est déjà une supercherie en
soi mais le fait de d'instrumentaliser
cela en créant
une fausse loi c'est à dire en créant un
système juridique qui va contraindre les
adolescents les enfants et même
d'ailleurs les adultes à se vacciner ça
ça contrevient à l'article 5 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
l'article 5 de restauration d'euros de
l'homme dit la chose suivante que nul ne
peut être contraint de faire ce que la
loi n'impose pas et on voit bien que
c'est pourtant ce que ce pass sanitaire
fait il nous contraint collectivement à
la vaccination alors que la loi ne
l'imposent pas donc le conseil d'état et
le conseil constitutionnel aurait
normalement dû se être vent debout
s'élever contre cette loi là ils ne
l'ont pas fait parce qu'ils participent
de la même un qui est une comme si
finalement cette épidémie était si grave
et si menaçante pour la vie des gens
alors qu'on sait très bien depuis le
début qui mena qui elles menacent
toujours les mêmes personnes très âgées
avec d'écomobilité ils font comme si
cette menace était si grande pour nos
libertés qu'il fallait empiéter sur ses
libertés pour nous protéger malgré nous
il ya une rupture de confiance on l'a
entendu ce soir il y à un écrasement des
libertés fondamentales il ya une
discrimination et aujourd'hui il ya une
ingérence dans l'école qui encore une
fois non justifiée parce que les données
médicales prouvent aujourd'hui les
données médicales pour certaines études
prouvent que ce n'est pas aussi évident
et qu'il faudrait être beaucoup plus
prudent en matière de juristes en
matière de jurisprudence c'est ce que le
gouvernement est en train de faire et
d'un point de vue légal et d'un point de
vue constitutionnel extrêmement
dangereux s'est mis man vous avez tous
les deux prononcer le mot de confiance
justement la république en marge qui dit
oui mais enfin on n'est pas sûr que les
déclarations que nous font les parents
sur la vaccination de leurs enfants est
vraiment exact en gros on a peur qu'il y
ait des fraudes qu'on nous mentent ça
vous inspire quoi justement tank
délégué proche des parents
écoutez d'abord je voulais revenir sur
les conséquences et puis joujou dire est
ce qu'on pense effectivement de 2,2
cette position face aux familles moi je
je je crains beaucoup ont toutes les
toutes mes collègues infirmières sont
les mêmes constatations les élèves ont
beaucoup souffert de ces deux années et
il ya eu un confinement une rupture du
lien social avec leurs camarades une
difficulté de se remettre au travail
quand on est contre les colas ouvert il
ya des conséquences qu'on voyait déjà
venir et qu'on est con sur lesquels on
alerte est quasiment depuis
plus d'un an non seulement à court mais
à moyen et long terme parce qu'on en ait
pas au bout et les jeunes qui viennent
nous voir dans les consultations
infirmières ces derniers mois ne vont
pas bien globalement y compris des
jeunes qui n'avaient pas de difficultés
particulières
précédemment à la crise sanitaire donc
le risque d'une stigmatisation par
rapport à leurs camarades fait face à
des décisions qu auront prises leurs
parents de vaccination ou non et pour
lesquels voilà il se retrouve bien
contraint de faire avec c'est quelque
chose qui va rajouter encore du mal être
dans une situation pour la jeunesse qui
est déjà très très compliquée depuis des
mois il va falloir qu'on prenne soin
d'eux et qu'effectivement on arrête de
rajouter des couches successives de
contraintes et d'injonctions quand on en
sort des familles c'est ce que je vous
disais en préambule
nous on a des contacts réguliers avec
les familles on est conseillère de santé
en tant qu'infirmière de l'éducation
nationale auprès des chefs
d'établissement de la communauté
éducative dont les parents qui depuis un
an et demi ne savent plus trop qui vers
qui se tourner entendent des
informations diverses ont parfois des
discours discordants entre ce que leur
dit la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie quand quelqu'un dans la famille
ou dans les proches
du réseau tourne autour d'eux a
contracté le virus le virus de l'aco
vide et qui entendent des discours
discordants entre la cpam les agences
régionales de santé et qui se tournent
vers les infirmières de l'éducation
nationale parce qu'on est un
professionnel de santé de proximité qui
nous font confiance moi je crois pas que
les parents aient envie de mentir je ne
pense pas qu'ils aient envie de mettre
la santé de leur enfant en danger la
santé des camarades non plus et encore
moins la santé des adultes qui
travaillent dans les établissements
scolaires je pense que si si c'est le
cas c'est quelque chose de très à la
marge est en tout cas c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on a pu observer depuis des
mois où on est déjà sur du déclaratif
quant à un enfant était contaminé
jusqu'à présent la famille n'avait pas
de certificat à remettre mais simplement
une déclaration sur l'honneur jeu on n'a
pas observé de deux flambées
décontamination depuis que ça c'est en
place dont je peux pas je peux pas on ne
peut pas accepter qu'on mette en doute
comme ça les intentions et la parole des
parents en tout cas c'est pas les
relations qu'on a avec eux au contraire
quand quand il ya des cas qu'on les
appelle pour les alerter sur un cas dans
la classe ou par rapport à leurs enfants
ils sont enfin ils sont réceptifs dans
la majorité des cas est plutôt prêts à
tout mettre en oeuvre pour que les super
on a entendu le message en tout cas
frédéric saint clair là on nous parle
d'ailleurs c'est toi on parle de la
troisième dose donc ne sonnerait le pack
sanitaires ou plutôt l inverse
il ya un moment jusqu'où va aller
l'acceptation des des français ce sera
ma dernière question
je me le demande sérieusement je vous
dis depuis le début de cette idée lui je
répète que les français sont magiques
majoritairement favorables aux pass
sanitaire c'est dire à quel point
l'emprise la tyrannie qu'opère cette
épidémie sur les consciences et
excessive
une grande majorité de français a perdu
sa lucidité et croit que la propagande
de propagande je pèse mes mots la
propagande gouvernementale et une parole
de vérité je vais vous donner un seul
exemple qui n'a été soulevée nulle part
le la loi qui vient d'être votée
prolonge la possibilité du passani terre
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 ce gouvernement
là l'exécutif ne sera plus en place en
2022 il ya des élections présidentielles
il y aura des élections législatives à
suivre on va valider une loi d'exception
qui place le pays dans une situation
d'urgence donc une situation d'exception
qu'il déroge au droit commun
jusqu'à une période où le gouvernement
n'est plus en place mais c'est mais
c'est impensable un truc pareil on peut
le faire avec une loi de droit commun
parce que cette loi de droit commun a
vocation à s'inscrire dans le long terme
une situation d'urgence elle est
directement politique donc elle a
vocation à s'arrêter à partir du moment
le gouvernement dé plus en fonction donc
on est dans une période complètement
folle en réalité ou à la fois les
dirigeants et les institutions qui sont
censés normalement opérées en tant que
contre pouvoir ont perdu de leur
lucidité et ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
comme vous l'avez souligné une grande
majorité de français et dans ce cas là
aussi et donc nous sommes minoritaires
aujourd'hui en france à ouvrir les yeux
et à ceux d'hier mais en fait nous
vivons dans une situation ubuesque c'est
aurélien est malheureusement quand on
est minoritaire dans une démocratie eh
bien on n'a pas la voix au chapitre donc
on en sort on subit on se mobilise mais
on subit merci beaucoup à tomber de
frédéric saldmann oui régis tchité voilà
je voudrais juste ajouté pour conclure
qu'il faut savoir effectivement raison
garder
qu'il faut protéger les jeunes parce que
c'est cela l'avenir c'est les citoyens
de demain et il faut il faut pas
sacrifier des générations au tour des
prétextes qui ne se justifie pas voilà
je vous remercie merci qui ont vous
remercions frais déclare également
les petits détours à présent dans le sud
de la russie avant de refermer cette
émission vladimir poutine a participé
aujourd'hui au club de discussion valdaï
à sotchi un rendez vous donné aux
dirigeants experts internationaux pour
parler du rôle de moscou dans le monde
alors que retenir de ce déplacement du
président en vue ces éléments de réponse
avec notre correspondante sur place
maëlys d'abstrait dans son discours et
lors de la séance de questions réponses
qui a suivi le président russe a
notamment évoqué la situation actuelle
en afghanistan d'après lui les
responsabilités de celle-ci incombe
principalement aux pays qui ont
participé à l'intervention et
l'occupation américaine écoutez la
grande responsabilité est assumée par
les pays qui ont fait la guerre là
dessus et la première chose qu'il
fallait faire c'est le dégel des avoirs
afghans et donner la possibilité à ce
pays de régler leurs problèmes du chef
d'état a précisé que le président
américain joe biden avait agi
correctement en retirant ses troupes
d'afghanistan même si d'après lui la
manière de le faire aurait pu être
différente l'adie mire poutine a ajouté
que moscou et pékin continuerait de
travailler ensemble pour établir un
dialogue dans le pays les relations avec
l'otan ont également été abordés à ce
sujet le président russe a affirmé que
dans leur déclaration les etats-unis
ouvraient defacto les portes de l'otan à
l'ukraine ce qui constitue d'après lui
une menace pour la russie je connais les
dispositions constitutionnelles de
l'ukraine personne interdit d'établir
une base de formation et sous le terme
de base de formation peut mettre
n'importe quoi
et ça a été dit publiquement donc demain
près de kharkov des missiles seront
installés et nous question c'est pas
nous qui pratiquons ingérence ici avec
nos missiles on oulémas soudanais pour
rappel cette intervention du président
russe qui aura duré plus de trois heures
clôture est la quatrième et dernière
journée du club de discussion valdaï
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi rendez vous lundi prochain
pour un non numéro en attendant
évidemment l'actualité continue toute la
soirée en direct sur rtl france
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un choix pour les
inspecteurs du guide michelin de mettre
cette année en particulier voilà moscou
en avant et sur ces dernières années nos
inspecteurs ont pu noter une vraie
évolution de la scène culinaire de
moscou et puis de plus en plus de
concept de restaurant et avec des chefs
qui ont une vraie signature dans leur
cuisine c'est en observant ce
développement que vous êtes dit on va
aller voir de plus près ce qui se passe
en russie moscou est un vrai carrefour
un vrai carrefour d'influencés un vrai
carrefour de deux cultures donc il ya un
vrai brassage donc à une très très
grande diversité des types de cuisine
moscou en particulier a une saveur
particulière
a ajouté à la scène gastronomique
mondiale
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
ap
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de films stratégies peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis au les chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rd france
[Musique]
et
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas de terreau vaty ressort du
politique il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï et gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]